a una semana de la llamada toma de Lima
jornada de protesta en la que diversos
colectivos sociales buscan la renuncia
de la presidenta de Dina boluarte el
cierre del Congreso y el adelanto de
elecciones el gobierno peruano extendió
el estado de emergencia por 30 días en
las principales vías nacionales al
respecto del Primer Ministro Alberto
tarola anunció que la medida es para
garantizar la integridad de la
ciudadanía así como el uso pleno del
derecho a circular libremente otarola
señaló que las protestas no deben
afectar los bienes públicos ni a las
personas días antes se dispuso el
despliegue de ocho mil policías en la
capital peruana ante las protestas que
se realizarán el próximo 19 de julio el
ministro del interior Vicente Romero ha
dicho que la policía actuará de acuerdo
a la ley para dar tranquilidad y
seguridad a los que protestan y aquellos
que quieran trabajar y no participar en
las marchas en paralelo los servicios de
inteligencia realizarán operativos de
control en las entradas a la Ciudad de
Lima donde se detendrán las personas que
tengan requisitoria por su parte El
Comando nacional unitario de lucha
organismo que agrupa dirigentes de
diferentes regiones del Perú afirmó que
de todas maneras alrededor de 30.000
manifestantes se trasladarán a Lima
situación que es rechazada por diversos
gremios empresariales porque aseguran
que el conflicto social generaría caos y
perjudicaría la economía del país